Ukraine's Army Chief says his forces are
making gains in the South but it remains
unclear whether Russia's begun pulling
troops out of the city of Hassan on
Wednesday Russia's defense minister said
he's ordered forces to withdraw to the
Eastern Bank of the danipro river near
Herson but Ukrainian officials are
worried their troops may walk into booby
traps or be ambushed we have three
reporters on this story in a moment
we'll get reaction from Muhammad Val in
Moscow and Jonah Hull in Keith but first
let's get the latest from assadbag and
zelen adults Assad what more can you
tell us what have you seen what have you
witnessed
well we've been in Carson this morning
and today and the artillery Bachelors
are still taking place you can still
hear the shelling taking place between
the two militaries the ukrainians and
the Russians and the missiles going
overhead but when you actually go
through her sign you realize that the
towns and Villages that the Russians
have withdrawn from now what happens is
that when the ukrainians take a village
or return her son is mainly rural
Flatlands so they end up taking loads of
territory but when the ukrainians take a
tunnel Village the ukr the Russians can
still shell them and that's exactly
what's been going on we've just come
from a town that's been completely
destroyed we went through it and there
wasn't a single building that hadn't
been damaged that didn't have shrapnel
damage or bullet holes there's no
electricity there's no water and there's
hardly anybody left we found a handful
of people and whether Russian forces had
been stationed well that was completely
destroyed and there was Weaponry that
was left behind now when we speak to
Ukrainian soldiers they're proceeding
with caution they don't trust the
Russians they don't trust these
announcements that have happened but
they also understand that even if they
manage to take her son's City the
Russian forces will be on the other side
of the river and still be able to Shelt
them still be able to hit targets uh in
in in her son and throughout Ukraine but
it will be a morel booster for many
people here especially at the time when
they're suffering from electricity and
water shortages and for countries that
are supporting Ukraine to see the
Ukrainian troops advancing but again
just for example when we were here
coming to our way here to be live to you
we had to stop because the ukrainians
had found some minds and they had to
detonate those before we could actually
proceed so that's still actually taking
place even though the Russian forces
won't be in certain areas there's still
this threat of booby traps and mines and
that's what the Ukrainian forces are
worried about when they actually go into
her son City well Assad we really
appreciate the update given everything
that just happened to us sad bag live
for us there stay safe
let's bring in Jonah Hull who is in the
capital Kiev Jonah what does this all
mean in terms of the war
probably frankly it's too early to say
what it all means in terms of The Wider
War context simply because it is unclear
what exactly is happening inside her son
City and on the West Bank of the danipro
river there yes there's been an order
given by the ministry of Defense in
Moscow to pull back from the West Bank
to the East Bank but that is not
something that will happen instantly and
nor was that order in point of fact
unexpected Russia has been preparing its
exit for some weeks now aware of the
vulnerability of its forces in terms of
that Northern counter-offensive being
mounted by the ukrainians and they've
been building defensive lines as they go
which is why as Assad said that they are
seeing mind land booby traps as those
forces move down from the North and the
big question is what will they encounter
when they get into Herson City itself
and that is something the ukrainians are
very worried about let me tell you what
the administration here in Kiev is
saying the most recent comments we have
from vehicle he's a senior advisor to
president zielinski saying that Russia
is likely to be booby-trapping the city
as it makes its exit from the city of
Herson mining everything it can from
Apartments to sewers planning then not
just to reduce the city itself to
violence as Ukrainian troops move in but
also to Shell it from the East Bank
where it has repositioned its artillery
units over the last few weeks planning
to turn it into he said a city of death
so the ukrainian's moving extremely
cautiously extremely carefully and of
course Vladimir zielinsky the president
himself last night talking about the
news as it was unfolding urging caution
urging restraint the enemy he said does
not bring us gifts it does not make
gestures of Goodwill we fight our way up
and we will move very very carefully
all right we appreciate the update Jonah
Hill Love For Us in Kiev let's head to
Moscow now where Mohammed Val is
standing by for us Muhammad how's the
withdrawal news gone down in Russia
well Emily uh it's a mixed reaction here
about this order to withdraw from Herson
but as you know when it comes to
decisions uh coming from the Supreme
leadership even the Hawks have to tow
the line we have for instance the
Chechen leader ramzan khajirov who wants
a more aggressive approach to the war
but he has supported the decision to
have her son to leave her son saying it
is that difficult but right choice
saving the Priceless the Priceless lives
of soldiers so the Hawks even though
they like this war to be tougher they
like action in Ukraine to be tougher
against the enemy they are Towing the
line as I said and they are supporting
this decision you know that also in
Russia most of the opposition is not
able to be heard because the opposition
cites websites and Outlets are
suppressed here most of the time but we
have set and voices who are opposed to
are opposed to this withdrawal for
instance we have a military blogger Yuri
kotenok saying the decision is shocking
to thousands and millions of people who
are fighting for Russia dying for Russia
believe in Russia and share the beliefs
of the Russian World so it's a mixed
reaction here and it is difficult to
gauge public opinion in the right way
but there are voices who are against
this withdrawal inside the country and
the Russians are divided in two camps
actually one of them is against the war
in the first place they are unhappy with
the war from the outset and those who
are now unhappy with how it is
developing all right we appreciate that
thank you so much Mohammed well live for
us in Moscow
NATO Secretary General Ian stoltenberg
says Russia's withdrawal from her son
shows how much pressure they're under
we have uh to see how the situation on
the ground develops in the coming days
but what is clear is that Russia is
under heavy pressure and if they leave
had some it would be another victory for
Ukraine
let's bring in Andreas unland who's in
Berlin he's an analyst at the Swedish
Institute of international Affairs
Andreas thanks so much for being on this
news hour what do you make of this move
is it humiliating for Russia or a
strategic play
well it is indeed for Russia and
embarrassment because
um Carson was
the only major
regional Capital that um
Russia was able to occupy and now it has
to also leave this Regional Capital it
has not been able to
capture another Regional Capital support
Asia although it has enacts the regions
of Herson and support Asia and it's now
outright paradoxical what is happening
because Russia is claiming territories
for annexation that it does not control
what do you make of the timing the
withdrawal was announced shortly after
Russian media revealed that the Moscow
appointed Deputy leader of her son was
killed in a suspected car crash
I don't think that stremusov's death
that's the name of the uh official
um plays much of overall here rather it
has purely military reasons that the
troops in her Zone were under strain and
they could not be supplied and so there
wasn't much Choice here for the Russian
military leadership than to withdraw
we've seen a pattern in this war that
every time Russia suffers a major
military setback there is a response
then targeting the civilian population
how cautious should Ukrainian officials
be
yes this has been the pattern that has
been emerging now that Russia simply
attacks civilian targets deep in the
Ukrainian Hinterland that do not have
actually any direct meaning for the war
itself for the fighting on the front
line but which are used as Targets in
order to exert pressure on the Russian
on the Ukrainian population or the
Ukrainian leadership on the West in
order to perhaps create then streams of
of refugees from Russia from Ukraine to
to the west and to put the entire
Ukrainian Society under stress
where does this leave negotiations to
end the war
well one could have negotiations but
it's difficult now to negotiate because
what is happening is now that we have
territories that are according to the
Ukrainian Constitution and to
international law Ukrainian territories
but these territories are under the
Russian Constitution Russian territories
and Putin is obliged by the Russian
Constitution to defend the Russian
Constitution and the territorial
Integrity of the Russian State and now
according to the Russian Constitution
these NX territories belong to the
Russian state so it's indeed difficult
to imagine what could be the subject of
such negotiations well we really
appreciate your analysis Andreas umland
in Berlin an analyst at the Swedish
Institute of international Affairs thank
you
thanks a lot
meanwhile Russian President Vladimir
Putin won't be attending the G20 leaders
Summit in Bali next week Russia is
likely to face Western criticism at that
meeting about the war in Ukraine Moscow
says foreign minister Sergey lavrov will
attend and Putin may appear on videolink
U.S President Joe Biden previously said
he had no intention of meeting Putin at
the G20